un objeto es lanzado desde una
plataforma su altura en metros x
segundos después del lanzamiento está
modelada por la función htx igual a
menos 5 que multiplican a x menos 4 esto
elevado al cuadrado más 180 y bueno
normalmente cuando hablan de tiempo
usamos la variable temp
tres segundos después del lanzamiento
pero en esta ocasión tenemos la variable
x así que vamos a concentrarnos no te
preocupes solamente recuerda que x
representa los segundos después del
lanzamiento y qué te parece si
visualizamos un poco lo que está pasando
con este problema para eso déjame
dibujar para cama dos ejes este va a ser
mi eje de la altura ok
esta es mi eje de la altura h y por acá
voy a tener mi otro eje que va a ser mi
eje del tiempo así que déjenme escribir
que este es mi eje del tiempo que está
dado por equis y ahora observa que
cuando el tiempo es cero
nosotros tenemos una cierta
una cierta altura que está como por aquí
aquí estamos en el tiempo x0 que es
justo la altura de esta plataforma y
luego vamos a lanzar el proyectil y este
va a tomar una forma de parábola así que
déjame dibujarlo así de hecho es una
parábola que abre hacia abajo déjame
ponerlo más o menos así es una parábola
que abre hacia abajo ok y si te
preguntas como sí que es una parábola
que abre hacia abajo la cual recuerda
está hecha a mano así que lo más
importante es que entiendas el punto y
no que tenga el dibujo perfecto pero la
forma en la que supe que es una parábola
que abre hacia abajo es observando esta
ecuación si observas esta es una palabra
escrita en su forma vértice es una
cuadrática tenemos una expresión de la
forma x cuadrada más algo más álbum y
después está x este menos 5 que nos dice
que es una parábola que va a abrir hacia
abajo
si hacemos este binomio al cuadrado me
va a quedar algo de la forma cuadrada
más algo más algo y luego al multiplicar
por este menos 5 su primer término va a
ser menos 5x cuadrada así que una vez
más vamos a tener una parábola que abre
hacia abajo que se ve más o menos así
entonces dada la intuición visual que
tuvimos veamos si podemos responder
algunas preguntas acerca de este
problema la primera que me gustaría
responder es qué tan alta es la
plataforma déjame notarlo
qué tan alta es la plataforma y te
invito a que pausas el vídeo e intentes
averiguarlo cuál es el valor justo aquí
como pueden ver estamos en el tiempo x
igual a 0 entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es evaluar esta función en 0
obtener el valor de h de 0 y bueno esto
va a ser si sustituimos a x por 0 es
menos 5 que multiplican am bueno me
quedaría menos 4 esto elevado al
cuadrado más 180 ahora observa sustituir
el valor de x por 0 y entonces aquí me
quedo menos 4 elevado al cuadrado y
bueno menos 4 elevado al cuadrado esto
es lo mismo que en 16 ok y después 16 x
menos 5 es lo mismo que menos 80 menos
80 más 180 bueno eso es lo mismo que 100
de lugo entonces ya sabemos que este es
el valor de 100 100
otros recuerdan su altura está dada en
metros entonces 100 metros es mi primer
respuesta ahora la siguiente pregunta
que tengo es cuántos segundos después
del lanzamiento alcanzamos nuestra
altura máxima porque observan vamos a
lanzar este objeto y en algún punto va a
llegar aquí donde vamos a tener la
altura máxima aquí tenemos un cierto
valor para x ok justo estamos buscando
este valor para x que nos va a dar
nuestra altura máxima y lo importante es
que si estamos hablando de una parábola
que abre hacia abajo entonces la altura
máxima se va a alcanzar
justo en el vértice dicho de otra manera
el valor x delbert se nos dirá cuánto
tiempo después del despegue nuestro
objeto ha alcanzado la altura máxima así
que déjenme anotarlo en cuánto tiempo
alcanzamos la altura máxima
y una vez más pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes encontrar la respuesta
muy bien estamos buscando la coordenada
x de nuestro vértice pero como la
encontramos bueno hay que observar esta
cuadrática que tengo aquí porque justo
la tenemos escrita en su forma vértice
lo que hace que se escuche como si
debiera ser relativamente fácil
encontrar el vértice y de hecho lo es
solamente tenemos que apreciar un poco
la estructura de esta expresión quiero
que entiendas que está pasando observan
este 180 y luego obtenemos este término
de aquí si observas este término de aquí
todo esto que estoy poniendo ahorita de
color verde tengo algo que va a ser
positivo x menos 4 al cuadrado siempre
va a ser mayor o igual que 0 y después
al multiplicarlo por un número negativo
vamos a obtener algo menor o igual a
cero así que todo esto todo esto que
tengo aquí va a ser menor o igual a cero
y por lo tanto le estaría quitando a
este 180 si nos ponemos a pensar un poco
el valor más grande que podemos tomar es
80 y eso lo podemos alcanzar cuando esto
de aquí sea igual a cero entonces esto
de aquí va a ser igual a cero si esta
parte de adentro va a ser igual a cero
si esto de aquí es igual a cero y esto
es igual a cero si x toma el valor de 4
así que cuando x toma el valor de 4
cuando x toman el valor de 4 encontramos
el punto máximo estamos en el best set
donde tomamos una altura ya sabemos que
esta altura de aquí es de 180 es lo
máximo que puede tomar esta función o
dicho otra manera es lo máximo que se va
a elevar nuestro objeto 180 metros así
que lo podemos escribir de esta manera
la función evaluada en x igual a 4
esto toma el valor de 180 y por cierto
es nuestro valor máximo de esta función
y la respuesta de en cuánto tiempo
alcanzamos la altura máxima
va a ser 4 segundos muy bien ahora la
última pregunta la última pregunta que
haremos es cuánto tiempo después del
lanzamiento llegamos a una altura de 0
es decir tocamos aquí el piso o también
lo podemos pensar como que x hacen esta
función 0 es decir vamos a buscar ahora
que x y déjame ponerlo por acá hacen a h
de x igual a 0 o de otra manera si pongo
aquí a hdx como menos 5 que multiplica a
x menos 4 esto elevado al cuadrado más
180 es igual a cero así que es buen
momento para que pause el vídeo y veas
si puedes resolver esta ecuación
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es
restar de ambos lados 180 y obtendría
que menos 5 que multiplican a x menos 4
esto elevado al cuadrado es igual a
menos 180 bien ahora vamos a dividir
todo entre menos 5 y si divido todo
entre menos 5 voy a obtener que x menos
4 ok elevado al cuadrado es igual
y bueno menos entre menos se cancela y
180 entre 5 es es 36 de lujo y ahora voy
a sacar la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados
y entonces me voy a quedar con que x
menos 4 es igual a más menos la raíz
cuadrada de 36 por tanto tengo dos
posibles soluciones la primera sería que
x menos 4
fuera esto igual a 6
que x menos 4 fuera igual a menos 6
ahora si sumo cuatro de ambos lados
en esta primera ecuación voy a obtener
que x es igual a 10 o en mi otra
solución es si sumo 4 de ambos lados que
x sea igual a menos 2 y ya tengo dos
soluciones para esta ecuación que hace a
htx igual a cero ahora hay que tener
cuidado porque este menos 2 habría sido
en el pasado si no estuviéramos
colocados aquí entonces seguimos la
trayectoria de esta parábola aquí
intersec haríamos en x igual a menos 2
pero estamos retrocediendo en el tiempo
así que esta no es la solución que
queremos tomar en consideración queremos
el valor positivo en el tiempo que es x
igual a 10 entonces justo aquí vamos a
tomar el valor de x igual am
diez diez segundos después del despegue
nuestra altura va a ser de cero si el
terreno está a una altura de cero
entonces nuestro proyectil va a tocar el
suelo